Their entire lives are flashing in front of their eyes!
I gotta give them the 10 on that one ladies and gentlemen!
They gave him a 50!
They gave Jordan a 50!
There's a lot of guys who can dunk
and who can jump
and do things but
I look for more than being able to execute it
That's just half of it. That just a piece of it
Can you just make it look easy?
You know that's when I am talking next level
The evolution of the dunk
opening the minds
of all of these athletes
these guys taking pieces of what people have done
paying homage
Dr. J
mid-70's here
This is something you don't see every day
He was showing...
how far he could fly
And that sends everyone reelin'!
The one thing I admired about this dunk
was that
yeah, guys can go
up high
but how far can you jump?
And the free-throw line was a
pretty solid landmark
Hmm
I already know what this is
That was powerful
You know, Dominique was a
I consider, you know
an angry dunker
I mean that's a two-hand windmill with authority from the sideline
What I look for
is full extension
full extension is a real windmill to me
Anything else is
papermills and you're just blowing little sheets of paper
off the table or something
Boom!
You can just see the power coming through
And you know, this is one of the dunks I personally...
could do
but not like that
Dee Brown
about to put the icing on the cake
Oh my! That's...
That's the cherry on the sundae!
That's the first question I asked him
as a teammate
Did you peek?
So this is from some distance
so you have to have trust
and I want to say he told me he practiced it a couple times
and like, if you don't know where the rim is
If you jump a little left
or a little right and you miss the rim
You're hittin' the ground
Who's thinking of this?
I mean that's impressive man
It's a combination of Dominique and Michael right here
It's a combination
I'm sitting there thinking
in between dunks like
What can I do? What can I do?
Nah, that's not good enough
All right Vince Carter with his first on the final round!
I come up with that
I didn't want an ooh, aah or nothin'
I just wanted the arena silenced
I wanted to show
height
above the rim
so I try to get the ball fully extended
high as I can above the rim
before coming down
At the same time I want to make sure
I'm high enough where I don't fall off
I took a risk
It made for a good competition
This here
is next level
Between the legs...
Good night, everybody...
Good night, ladies and gentlemen
He took it in front of the free-throw line
showing distance, obviously
hang-time ability
That's impressive, man
hands down
I mean it's just, the next level
in the evolution of the dunk
and what's being done
is guys taking pieces
of what former dunkers have done
and putting their twist on it
You know, just when you think
What else could you do?
What could be done?
Guys have the God-given ability
to just go, "hey
Imma do what I do"